hi everyone it's Jerry there's another
group of five puzzles all of them are
white supply and it's up to you to
determine the best continuation in each
case so in this first one go ahead pause
the video see if you can find the best
continuation for white ok the solution
to this one is rook to g4 very forcing
continuation pawn takes rook is the only
move Queen g5 Czech King h8 is the only
move and after Queen of h6 black could
basically resigned because there's not a
successful way to defend against both
made threats namely Queen takes rook and
Queen takes pawn and so black is going
to be lost at this point
so moving on to the second puzzle once
again white to play pause the video see
if you can find the best continuation
for white ok the solution to this one
starts off with Bishop takes pawn and
it's important to take into account that
trying to get your Queen here and then
sneak in on h7 or each 6 etc to give
mate
that's not going to work because the
rook can always contest the H file
actually first throwing in a check and
then let's say rook to age 8 and there's
not going to be a way to really make
much progress against the black position
and so the more forceful continuation is
Bishop takes pawn and just the threat of
winning the bishop or even landing a
check on g8 picking off that rook really
there's not going to be a whole lot to
do besides just Bishop takes Bishop and
now after Queen to f6 a very a very
forceful move if the King goes to g8
that'll just run into maid on h8 with
either the queen or Brooke so after
Bishop takes Queen now we have a mate in
three ropes g3 and the best that black
can do is just you know block with the
Queen and then block with the bishop
this will turn out to be checkmate so
that's the solution to puzzle 2 moving
on to the third one once again white to
play pause the video see if you can find
the best continuation for white ok the
solution to this one is d8 equaling a
knight and there's not really a whole
lot that black can do here because the
black queen is now caught in a crossfire
and so after it moved like Queen takes
Queen we have the night giving a fork I
takes Queen discovered check and let's
say after came to f6 the knight grabs
this pond and this is going to be a
completely won endgame even if this b3
pond Falls certainly having two nights
that are able to coordinate themselves
and in addition to that having two extra
ponds on the Kings side is going to be
equating to a win so that's the solution
to puzzle three moving on to the fourth
one once again like to play pause the
video see if you can find the best
continuation for white ok the solution
to this one is the very silent but very
strong
rook to see one threatening Bishop takes
on h7 winning the black queen not really
a whole lot that can be done if black
tries account like an in-between type of
move like rook there again that's not
going to work out very well at all
because of this sort of a situation
white would be winning and so a
different try might come in the form of
let's say queen d4 however after Bishop
to f5 this is going to translate into a
win as well in the form of let's say
Queen takes Queen pawn takes Queen this
rook is hit and it cannot move to a
square where it still watches over that
c6 Knight and so this would be winning
from this position and showing one more
variation after Queen to a5 we would
have Bishop to f5 hitting that rook if
we have rook to ca a really nice shot
the King is now tied down to the defense
of the rook and we could use the tactic
of deflection grabbing on h7 and then
grabbing the rook which is a win and
finally one other continuation being
after Bishop to f5 rook on F to d8 could
be met with just Bishop takes rook rook
takes Queen and after pawn takes rook
this Knight is going to end up falling
because of the main threat on ei
black has to either save the king or
save the knight and so this is going to
be a win for white so
moving on to the last one once again why
to play pause the video see if you can
find the best continuation for white ok
the solution to this one is pond to v8
promoting to a bishop very rare case
where you promote to a bishop let's have
a look at first why that is the case for
example going with the typical promotion
to a queen
what black can now do is draw this game
in the form of rook to e2 and so giving
essentially checks wherever that white
King goes if the if the rook is ever
grabbed is going to be stalemate the
black King cannot move anywhere and so
if the King just walks in this direction
the rook just keeps giving check
wherever the King goes and so if the
White King goes in the other direction
like c1 we give check once again if the
King goes to b1 it's important not to
make use of that be too square because
the Queen could always recapture and the
King would have that a7 Square available
but instead King c1 and now if let's say
King b2 we give check and white would do
best to just grab the rook at this point
otherwise they run the risk of losing
the game and if instead of that King a2
now we have the rook going to a1 King b2
King b1 finally by force we could have
this situation where white pretty much
just has to grab that rook if instead of
promoting to a queen we had something
different for example promoting to a
rook well now we just have them a more
or less drawn position there's not
really a whole lot going on promotion to
a knight would lead to just king to a
seven-night check King to b6 and now
both of these Knights are under attack
one of them is going to be lost
so certainly promoting to a knight is
not good promoting to a bishop is the
only way to win and that's because light
will now be able to win both of these
ponds and have a1 endgame for example
rookie to king d1 rook a - even though
this pawn is going to fall for example
let's just say 94 taking this pawn right
now is
good because we just grabbed that pond
and land a fork but instead if we had
came to be six again this pond is
targeted it's not going to be able to be
saved
Bishop takes pawn check King c7 Bishop
takes pawn here this is going to be a
win it's going to take a little bit of
time but certainly too connected passed
pawns two minor pieces that we'll be
able to coordinate themselves
in the white king being able to help out
in that task is going to translate into
a win for white so that's all for this
video as always I hope you got something
out of it and be sure to let me know how
you did on these puzzles take care bye